last time that we were talking you
mentioned
that uh you're really into karaoke
and during coven i'm wondering is that
something you're able to do at home
do you do a lot of karaoke at home so
it's kind of gotten a bit out of hand i
i i have i i've managed to have homes
that have basements in them
and uh i it started
with like one little karaoke machine and
like a string of lights and it's evolved
into uh the next house that i moved into
had a giant basement and i
i basically spent this year turning it
into
a 1960s tiki karaoke lounge
like with vintage furniture and like i
painted all the walls and i hung like
disco
lights and it's very elaborate like
somebody walked down there the other day
and
looked at me like i was crazy they were
like what is this
you know you know what it sounds like to
me evan it sounds like a code violation
it sounds like you are running a
legitimate polynesian restaurant
in your basement it i could
yes i could probably i need a permit for
this um
so yes i i have been able to carry a few
i actually just celebrated my 33rd
birthday and um safely had you know
people tested
like three people who came over and we
actually
reenacted like every broadway show in
the basement complete with
a version of it's a hard knock life with
my friends
with mops and brooms doing a whole
choreographed
number and it was it was wonderful yeah
it was very needed in such a
gloomy time it's just pure silliness
you're you're i know that you love
music and uh anyone who loves music or
even doing stand-up or working in front
of a live crowd
that's what we're all jonesing for
during covet i mean i miss i really miss
restaurants
and i miss audiences um
and i'd love to eat a really good meal
in front of an audience that would be
my dream to you know in covid fantastic
yes but i would like to just blow up
blow out my birthday candles you know
you can't even like people can't even
blow out their birthday candles on their
cakes
right that's right well you're banned uh
but it's evident zayn what was the last
um performance that you did what was the
last
could you remember because i can
remember my last
live performance i think was in this
theater
like and then two days later everything
was shut down
so i have this fond memory do you
remember the last time that you
guys perform live yes the last time we
performed live
every year we do um an anti-valentine's
day show we've we've kind of turned
february 15th
into the polar opposite of valentine's
day because
our band started with this idea i had of
you know singles
and broken-hearted people have nowhere
to go during this holiday so i was like
let's cram a bunch of people into a bar
and sing just the saddest most
depressing songs about heartbreak
and misery and it turned out to be this
very cathartic amazing night so now
we've made it an annual thing
um and so yeah february 15th i believe
was our last show
live um and we just performed our first
streaming show and you must be able to
relate to this how
no one claps after anything that you do
like no one laughs at jokes
no one you mean are you talking about
during
during zoom or in my entire career
i don't know during zoom i disturbed
that one appropriate
um but i know what you mean because uh
we're just weird we're used to feedback
yeah
feeding off of the audience is energy we
have none of that and so you don't know
whether or not
you're bombing or what um we did a rage
against the machine
song uh killing in the name and
man i think that's the first time that
song has ever been played to just a room
full of no one
and the song ends with me just screaming
at you i won't do what they tell me like
over and over and i really went for it
just
after that you taught me and then trash
like i'm like dripping sweat yeah it's
it's it's a very strange experience
yeah and then then the doorbell rings
and it's your postmates delivery
exactly exactly exactly or like somebody
interrupts the streaming with like a
text message or a zoom call or something
sorry sorry my son my son runs on a
stage puts a fireman hat on me you know
he's like
that's how it works yeah yeah maybe
maybe you just have to shelve rage
against the machine
during you know until you get an
audience back or just lean in maybe we
should just
only do crazy loud songs and just just
go for it
you know what i should start doing is
telling jokes and when i don't get a
response
lose my temper and yell as if
what the f's your problem yeah
man no this is a pretty good joke what's
wrong with you and just
completely escalate until i'm taken away
that would be great
there you go we're we're getting close
we're getting close